oh I'm skinning here Oh My Orders a guy
I got my god I'll revive you pistol
what's up sport Bible I'm Benny central
and welcome to celebrity squad battles
kick of the series we've assembled a
squad of England stars who think they're
pretty good at FPS is but we'll be the
judge of that
so let's see what they've got alright
guys I am now joined by Trent Jesse and
Joe and we're hopping into about four
five main thing is stick together right
in conquest have got to try and hold as
many [ __ ] as we can and I've chosen
medic as well so I will head over
towards see any way to start off with
anyone played wait wait you bye-bye
where do I see I yeah if you come pick
us a lot yeah drive towards us drive
towards us you'll see us with with the
green dots on the map so we're we're
head towards see anyway but yeah that's
all group up let's all get in the
vehicles and we're all together you get
so many more points and then you can get
these like kind of reinforcements I'm on
the gun
this is this little Smee bro I'm sure
survivors to see everyone get out the
big wave will gala vehicle
I remember your grenades also new left
bumper said you pro press like bumper
you've got your grenades well I'm coming
over
oh wow yeah we're all dead we're dead
not other than Jesse Jesse's ass at
their own ad
but this rib eye but you're the medic
get out we're back hold X all right get
us up I'm waiting with you I'm waiting
whoa the vibe me X yes all right Thank
You Jesse one right wait right let's
print your on your onesie you guys
come towards me alright so we're
planning for pop this around side of all
I being out here you know these nice
open by the front I don't like it
see if you just move left a little bit
I'm claiming your space and just hit
that tank
oh my orders a guy oh my god oh my god
I'll revive you I'm a Bible how did I
think you've been doing best with us is
I kind of sticking with everyone kind of
grouping up right but just trying car
people they're a little bit slow cure'
dying so much right because you're
constantly just pushing out my stunt no
oh no get out it's gonna blow up well as
I said die
although and then Trent I don't know
where just lay up Frankie how do you
think that one do you think the viewers
are gonna be I think we're a week
squadron to work on a chemistry trench
this and on Maisie run to eat their
deaths was our and about obviously you
know we're doing much different world
what are you going to say about that
trend I think if we were off all of us
the in same position and he targets we
have to branch out a little bit
I see we going but like you know I kind
of got things big thing about
battlefield 5 squad play you're gonna
get more points right you're gonna be
able to revive each other right so I'm
we've drawn this jest suggest a who do
you think right I've Joan Trent was the
MVP
you know often Lee both works out for
the scenes honest I think soon as Trent
turned into us my poor picking out those
shootings in the real trend alright guys
so make sure to tune in on to Sport
Bible for a Facebook live scene where
you can go up against our so tune in
then and get involved and you know will
be better swept by them
[Music]